it's a dynamic gameplay and that's in
and that's really where I think that I
have an advantage is that people are
comfortable with what they know they
freak out with the unknown and they
don't know how to be dynamic and adjust
where I'm going in it with a mobile or
agile game plan okay I can hear all your
tech terms coming up so you got to be
careful with that in the house well I am
the Technical Sales I don't even know
what it means I heard guys say it once
[Music]
my name is Brett and I live in Boston
Massachusetts and why big brother Brett
oh wow
big brother is exciting so so my
favorite part about it is it's the
truest form of a social experiment I'm
just fascinated with social engineering
and this is really the only way I'll get
to really exercise it
yeah social engineering that's an
interesting term I haven't heard much of
today well that would be my
cybersecurity background playing into it
so a lot of people think when they hear
cybersecurity all you think about some
techie nerd and throw them in the corner
and shut up but really there's a lot of
social engineering that goes into it how
do I get someone to do something like
click on that link because they still
need their human interaction to to
deliver that and that's where the social
engineering comes into play how do I
strategically plan something out and get
the desired result all right I'm
starting to see the wheels turning of
this is my strategy in the house you're
gonna use some of this background from
the real world in the Big Brother house
correct I should go into the house are
you gonna keep it a secret what you do
absolutely
okay what's the cover story I'm just
gonna say I'm in technical sales which
isn't it which isn't too far off I
support the sales teams at time and
essentially to say hey listen have your
nerd talk to miner to make sure it all
checks out sounds boring enough that
nobody will ask you many questions I'll
just say hey I'm in technical sales and
I and I you know you know what I sell
this stuff I don't even know what it
does okay there we go
easy enough why not answer and not gonna
throw anybody for like a I'm gonna look
into that more exactly all right this is
Big Brother 20 big season big season
what twists are you hoping for well
twist am i hoping for a while I'm hoping
they grant me safety happy but you know
big twist that I'm hoping for I'm hoping
for no twist so that I can plan this out
and actually okay are you would you
consider yourself a casual viewer a
superfan somewhere in-between by I'm a
big fan I I'm not gonna put myself as a
superfan yet those guys are diehards and
they know I'll grant them they've been
dubbed their crown a superfan they get
you out super family I'm a big fan
though I again a lot of it for me is is
the social strategy like I'm fascinated
with that so the fact that you can put
people in the house and everyone knows
it's it's not you know it's not it's
easy to live someone in the real world
they don't know what your motive is and
people let their guards down but to put
everyone in the house and say we're all
gonna lie to each other and still get
the desired result like that's that's
the Battle of the Titans right there
yeah that's fascinating to me kind of
the only place where that happen you
know I'm going to lie to you but I'm
still gonna get you to do what I want
how do you do that so that's that's
really where the fun comes in okay and
you're very into the psychology of all
of this absolutely
is there any player from Big Brother
history that you're gonna emulate or
kind of hold something so they're in
question and everyone asks that and I
think the biggest mistake that you can
make is to emulate your play off of a
previous player and the reason is is
everyone already knows what that
person's done so they know how to stop
them also if you go into the house
assuming that the environment is gonna
be the same as a prior season you're
wrong and you're in your ego well I
already made my plan I'm gonna stick to
it while you're an idiot because it's
the ompletely different environment so
it's a dynamic game play and that's and
that's really where I think that I have
an advantage is that people are
comfortable with what they know they
they freak out with the unknown and they
don't know how to be dynamic and adjust
where I'm going in it with a mobile or
agile game plan okay
I can hear all your tech terms coming
out so you got to be careful with that
in the house well I am a technical
I don't even know what it means I heard
you guys say it once sounds good yeah it
sounds good
a twist could be maybe some vets come
back and play the game again is there
anybody you would love to see play the
game well so I mean like I'd love to see
Jessica play again cuz I don't think
she's a threat but I'd like to watch her
play and I mean she's pretty and I mean
that in the nicest way I'm a gentleman I
you know I'm not I'm not trying to push
my way on anyone by any means but at the
end of the day I do I think that I could
beat her in the game yeah I don't want
anyone coming back that they think I
could truly lose against who we do not
want to see back in the house that's
that's a tough question so I would say
Derrick or I would say Paul but I still
think it's to my advantage now because
everyone already knows like Frances
Derek everyone knows he's done
undercover cop and he would just set off
so many alarms that it would be haywire
I don't know what would happen but he
was also a fan favorite he really played
the game as a true gentleman and one he
didn't do it in this crazy deceiving way
he just went super under the radar did a
really good job at that
and I really I honor him for that but
then you have the other side of the
fence where it's Paul and it's like the
craziest like puppeteering that you've
ever seen and I and I and I truly dub
him for that as well but I think that he
would set off a lot of bells and
whistles coming into but as you remember
from season 19 a lot of people just like
the power team they just sucked on the
power to you and Paul and hopefully
people would see the bells and whistles
and not do that again
but again you never know until you're in
that time can't predict it exactly this
game can get pretty vicious it can how
vicious are you gonna get on a scale
like 1 to 10 I don't plan I plan to go
in to be a gentleman I want to be the
guy that's gonna make my momma proud but
the other day I'm going for five hundred
thousand dollars so you know I'm gonna
do whatever it takes but you have to be
smart about it because people get
passionate and that's why the show is so
great to watch you have to be very
careful about your passion because you
can always apologize but people are
never gonna forget what you say yeah and
you can't edit and people are always
looking for an exploit if you give them
the opportunity and get too passionate
they're gonna use that and they're gonna
get you out so much of this is the
social side of things a lot of it a huge
part of it
I would say it's really just is is a
domination of emotional control control
your emotions it's a true art and it's
it's a skill that most lack something
that can get in the way of controlling
emotions a showmance yeah are you
interested in what are you going and
looking for what hey listen it I'm
interested in the money but at the end
of the day I'm a red-blooded American
male I can't help myself
you know my mind turns to mush sometimes
when a pretty girl walks in the room and
I don't even know what I'm doing
but the plan is to stay focused and stay
driven okay I have the prize of the
money and if a girl comes along you know
maybe well because the other side of it
is is there's there's a social game to
it that's a guaranteed additional vote
as long as you don't mess it up yeah and
then that's a guaranteed not vote so you
have to play it well and again it's all
gonna become a game time decision this
isn't something if I made the decision
right now it would be negligent on my
part got it all right so you're gonna
keep your professional background a
secret is there anything else that
you're nervous to share with your fellow
houseguests no no I'm gonna be I'm gonna
try and play it true I don't I don't see
anything else other than might lie about
my college degree because it plays well
with you know my cybersecurity
background its management information
systems I might play it down and say
it's marketing I don't know marketing
isn't smart I'm not saying that
Mario watch a million people that's not
what I'm saying but I might just make it
a little bit more business associated
and that's how I got into sales okay
you've had some time to think about this
I've had plenty of time the show also
has a way of bringing out secrets from
people's lives the outside of the house
is there anything you want to confess to
now that might come out while you're in
that house well you're gonna find out
that I'm a mama's boy and I'm a
red-blooded American male that's about
it okay what does mama think about you
going and doing this crazy thing oh I
think mom's always nervous when I'm in
the spotlight but she's supportive of
everything you gotta buy her something
nice when you get that that's the plan
everyone says what are you gonna do with
the money I'm gonna take my mom on a
nice trip good good theoretically you're
going into this house for three months
knock down what are you gonna miss most
about the outside world
I miss most the outside world man I miss
gonna get sushi suits like having like
having certainly cook for me like I hate
doing dishes but I can put up with that
you know that's that's not a big deal
yeah a big bit most difficult thing for
me it's gonna be music oh yeah that's
hands there I'm gonna because I workout
with music like that's how I get through
my day it's like man this sucks how it
can make it a little bit better let's
put on some music I'm driving in traffic
let's put on some music
now having music that's gonna definitely
be the hardest part for me should you
get HOH in there what's gonna be the one
CD that you're like get me that all
right so it's so embarrassing on my part
but like who buy CDs anymore like I'll
buy a whole album like I have like songs
so if I had to pick and if I'm allowed
to workout with the music I like some
dr. dre oh and I like some or like some
Drake or I like some Waka Flocka
but then if I'm like hanging out I can
get you know I can get a country boy I
can get in some Luke Combs or some Jason
Aldean I'm all over the spectrum oh yeah
so it's really all in on mood but I
think that that's gonna be the hardest
parts cuz a lot of times when when my
emotions are high strong and I'm out
there on the spectrums and I'm trying to
reel myself back in I use music to get
myself back down and calm down it's like
it's like my outlet okay you know that's
gonna be tough because they won't even
let you sing in there you can't even
home you don't even home a tune I
sometimes wake up singing a song I'm
like I didn't even know that song for
one's bed I don't know where it came
from all right so we're gonna miss sushi
and music and you know anything that
you're loving that you won't have to
deal with for three months working I'm
going to work every mug traffic
commuting and traffic I will not miss
driving at all commuting in traffic
that's I'm totally contentious all right
yeah your commute will be just down a
flight of stairs or across Arabia
exactly to wrap things up here why are
you gonna win big brother I'm gonna win
big brother
using my social engineering background
to exploit vulnerabilities that is
within the house succinct answer I like
it well good luck in there hopefully I
don't see you until finale night that's
the plan
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]